the media and democratic assault on the
police continues democrats move to make
washington dc estate and joe biden
prepares crippling sanctions against the
american economy
banking on natural post-pandemic growth
to save them i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing
at expressvpn.com ben we'll get to all
the news in just
one moment first let's be frank about
this everybody has rights to express
yourself freely the bad news is big tech
doesn't really want you to do that in
fact what they would prefer is just they
can track all of your activity and
monetize all of your activity
and then use all of your data against
you well why would you give them that
ability instead use expressvpn
if you've ever wondered how free to
access tech giants make all their money
the answer is they track your searches
video history everything you click on
they build a profile on you and then
they sell off your sensitive data when
you use the expressvpn app on your
computer or phone you anonymize much of
your online presence by hiding your ip
address that makes your activity more
difficult to trace
and sell to advertisers what's more
expressvpn encrypts 100
of your network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cybercriminals what i
love most about
this is how easy it is to use once it's
on your phone or your computer you click
one button and now you are protected
it's super simple revoke big tech's
right to your data today secure your
internet with the vpn i trust for online
protection visit expressvpn.com
ben that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn dot com
slash ben get three x four months free
with my exclusive link go to
expressvpn.com
again that's expressvpn.com slash ben
alrighty so
the for some odd reason the makia bryant
case continues to bubble in the media
today now
this is a perfectly obvious case where
the police did the right thing
i mean 100 percent obvious not 90
obvious
not 95 obvious 100 percent obvious that
makia bryant was wielding a knife and
she's about to stab a girl and a police
officer shot her
and because the media and because the
democrats and because the white house
have all decided that the cops are bad
they're making this an issue
they're no longer pretending that this
is about bad cops
they're no longer pretending this is
about cops doing bad things they're now
pretty much coming out right up front
and saying even when cops do good things
they are bad because america is racist
and the system is terrible
this is the entire case being made by
the democrats now we'll get more black
people killed
as we have been talking about since 2014
between 2014 2019
at least one to six thousand more people
died in major cities where there were
ferguson
style blm protests most of those people
presumably were black
in the last year alone 34 biggest cities
in america 30
increase in homicide in some cities like
milwaukee there's like 75 percent
increase
in homicide when you get rid of the cops
more black people die
and when you demonize the cops such that
they don't want to do their jobs anymore
or they simply quit
there is no way to enforce the law and
it turns out that the greatest
preventer of people doing crime is
police officers
the people who stand between you and the
criminal those are the cops
and when you rip on the cops all day
long when you make it impossible for
them to do their job
and when they do do their job and they
should do something heroic by you know
stopping somebody from stabbing another
person
using the appropriate level of force
which is what happened in the makia
bryant shooting
then you still demonize them and you
treat them like garbage and i'm hearing
from cops
all week long i've been hearing from
cops via text message via email
via phone telling me that they are
quitting
in california i heard from a friend who
i have and in one of the major police
departments in california
that he knows three officers who came
into the office yesterday
and just slammed down their badges on
the desk and said we're out you're going
to see this across
the country and the people who pay for
that are not people like me
i'm not going to pay for that because i
live in an area that has a police force
that is well liked by the population
it's not going to matter for the people
on cnn it's not going to matter for the
people on msnbc
it's not going to matter for ibram kendy
who has his police protection over it
boston university center for anti-racism
it's not going to matter at the green
room
at any of these networks or at the
editorial page over the new york times
which has its own private security not
going to matter for any of those folks
the people it's going to matter for are
the people who live in these cities
who are being conditioned by the media
to believe that the cops are their enemy
and are not going to have a cop to call
when it comes time to call a cop because
there's somebody running around the
neighborhood with the gun shooting
people
okay here's how the washington post is
covering the mckea bryant
killing the headline from the washington
post this is at the top
of their page today makia brian's family
remember her as loving
affectionate she didn't even have a
chance to live her life
okay now the headline here is that she
was attempting to stab
another girl with a butcher knife
it seems like that should be the
headline it turns out that all human
beings
are are shaded all human beings are
nuanced you can find the worst human
being on earth and they probably have a
good relationship with at least a couple
of people
i don't know what circumstances led
makia bryant to pick up a knife
and charge another human being and try
to stab that human being
i don't know the circumstances what i do
know is that the cop doesn't have to
know those circumstances to know
it is his job to prevent the stabbing
the entire media apparently now coming
out in favor of the idea
that if you are black and you stab
another black person that is better than
if a cop stops you from stabbing the
other black person
that is the way that the media treats
all of these cases
and or they engage in the speculative
fiction in which they as police officers
would have magical jack-bower-like
abilities
they'd be like the frisco kid or they'd
be like gene wilder in blazing saddles
where they can
shoot the trigger fingers of bad guys or
they can shoot guns out of people's
hands
all of this is ridiculous on its face
now the way that we know this is
ridiculous on its face is because not
only do we have the original body cam
angle on the mickey of ryan shooting
in which you can see clearly makia
bryant charging at this other girl
who's pinned against a car and raising a
butcher knife to sh
to stab her we now have another angle on
the makia brian shooting
this angle shows that makia bryant
is is lunging at another woman with a
knife
and people are shouting about it people
are
here here's the video
okay she's shouting that she's gonna
stab somebody
she also i'm gonna effing kill you as
the cop attempts to de-escalate like
what is is there is there possibly
better evidence that the cop did the
right thing here okay but according to
the media remember
the cop can do the right thing and it
doesn't matter because every bad thing
in america that happens if it happens to
a black person
is an element of systemic racism right
everything is attributable to the system
because the goal here is not to make
life better for people
the goal here is to tear down the
systems the same systems by the way
that have provided for more freedom and
more security
in the past half century than black
people have anywhere else on planet
earth
america is an incredible place for black
people to live
it is better than virtually all other
places on planet earth
by polling data america is one of the
least racist countries on earth
black household income is higher in the
united states than it is anywhere else
on planet earth
this notion that america is some sort of
hellscape for black americans compared
with other countries on earth
is completely evidence-free but that is
the proposal that all of america's
institutions are are terrible and that
every bad thing that happens to a black
person
or for which a black person is
responsible is attributable generally
to the system at large as i talked about
a little bit earlier this week this is
the soft bigotry of low expectations
it's not it's just the
hard bigotry of no expectations in a
free country
where the law applies black people
apparently have no agency at all and are
not to be held responsible for their
actions in any way
which is why you end up with articles in
the washington post talking about she
didn't even have a chance to live her
life
this is all about the system
bryant beams at her mother in a
tick-tock clip then throws her arms
around her neck
as beyonce's dance for you plays in the
background the team lip syncs the lyrics
i'ma take this time to show you how much
you mean to me because you are all i
need
it's an intimate moment between mother
and daughter who are working hard to
reunite after bryant was placed in
foster care family member said
they had a close bond said don bryant a
cousin of makia's mother mckee was just
an all-around good person
on tuesday 16 year old bryant was
fatally shot by a columbus police
officer responding to a call for help
at her foster home in the city southeast
body camera footage released by police
shows brian swinging what appears to be
a knife at two people during an
altercation outside the property before
an officer arrives and fires four shots
at her torso
on thursday family members struggle to
make sense of the killing at least the
third fatal shooting by columbus police
this year
okay but how many of those were
justified do we have the details on any
of those because this one was it was a
justified shoot
don bryant said he had a hard time
recognizing the teen seen in the police
video lunging at others
he doesn't condone any violence but
called the officer's decision to open
fire disproportionate
there are other disengagement techniques
police could have used here
said bryant who has served on the
mansfield ohio city council i'm a
supporter of police's former city
councilor
i understood their moves their tactics
what they do i just don't understand
what happened here you don't understand
what happened here i mean it seems
pretty clear what happened here since
it's you know on tape from several
different angles
the the entire media coverage here
is angled toward ignoring the actual
circumstances of the case
officials identified the officer who
fired the shots as nicolas reardon and
said he had been taken off street duty
while the investigation proceeds
reardon 23 appears to be the son of a
retired columbus police sergeant named
ted riordan an air force veteran
and long time basic training instructor
instructor at the department's training
academy
when ted reardon retired last year the
department posted a tribute video
nicholas ridden was a high school
wrestler at columbus's bishop watterson
high school
the wrestling team's twitter feed showed
him posing with his dad as a senior in
2016. he joined the columbus pd in
december 2019.
the shooting immediately ignited debate
about whether deadly force was warranted
okay well that debate ignited because
the biden administration jumped on this
to suggest that the shooting was wrong
and again
emblematic of of white systemic racism
but i'll tell you what it really was
emblematic of more than anything else
how many of these cases are parents
really deeply involved with the people
who end up shot by the police
seriously are we allowed to ask that
question
because we have on tape mckea bryan's
mother giving tearful interviews
but makia bryant was in a foster home
when she attacked another girl with a
knife where was michael bryan's mother
then
here's mickey o'brien's mother on cnn my
heart is really broken right now because
i miss my baby to be honest i miss
already
and it's really hard
for me i haven't eaten
and i can't eat because i miss my baby
i had a beautiful baby
she was taken from me okay your how
your heart goes out for the mother at
the same time where was mom
makia bryant was in a foster home where
was mom adam toledo was shot in chicago
again a justified shooting it was
treated by the media as an unjustified
shooting the adam toledo shooting
where were adam toledo's parents adam
toledo had been missing for two nights
he's a 13 year old boy on the streets he
had joined the latin kings which is a
gang in chicago
he just gotten a tattoo to that effect
and he was shooting weaponry at cars
where were his parents you want to talk
about alleviating problems why don't we
start with some of the roots of the
problems rather than blaming the people
who are charged with basically putting a
band-aid on criminality by attempting to
stop the criminals
but again you can't talk about that
because if you talk about that then it
devolves to personal responsibility
and the left has suggested black people
have no agency in america it is the hard
bigotry of no expectations if there is a
bad situation then we're just supposed
to expect that there will be widespread
riots
if there is a if there is a black girl
who
tries to stab another black girl with a
knife she has no responsibility for
those actions
nor do we care only if the cop shows up
to stop it do we care because that's
emblematic of systemic racism
this is what ibrahim kennedy says zebra
mkhindi who is just a grifter and a race
baiter and
a person with terrible awful horrible
ideas he's a tyrant
here he is on cnn with brianna keeler
talking about how the cops should never
have done this
when i look at that video i i asked
myself
if if that would have been a 16 year old
white girl in a wealthy suburban
neighborhood
would the police officer have sought
to disarm this girl would the police
officers
sought to talk her down would the police
officer you would have used
legal lethal force and it's hard for me
to believe
that that would have happened it's hard
to me to to believe that that
officer uh would not have responded
differently
for a different girl in a different
community okay we'll get to the details
of what exactly he means by all of that
because it is wrong in about seven
different ways
but first let's talk for a second about
the fact that everything you have these
days is personalized right your drinks
are personalized your food is
personalized everything is personalized
to you and that's great
but why wouldn't you personalize a thing
that you spend so much of your time on
namely your mattress helix sleep has a
quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep
heelys has several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium firm mattresses mattresses great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again just go to dot com slash ben
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will i know because my wife and
i have taken that two minute sleep quiz
and we sleep like babies on that
mattress when our kids allow us to
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
your mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.comhelixsleep.com get up to
200 bucks
off your mattress order at
helixsleep.com okay so everyone kenny
says a few things there
one he suggests that if the police
officers showed up they would try to
talk down
a white girl who's doing this to another
white girl in an upper income
neighborhood okay now notice how he adds
an upper income neighborhood
this wasn't an upper income neighborhood
right this is a pretty obviously lower
income neighborhood
the income the class gap does matter
here a little bit which i'll explain in
a second
but the notion that a police officer
even would have had time to talk to
makia bryant belies the facts
there's a grand total between the time
the officer the officer arrives he steps
out of his car he says what's going on
between that time and the shoot is nine
seconds
nine seconds you think of that night
what was he supposed to do
get out of the van and ask mackie bryant
about the trouble she's experiencing in
her life or you know stop
her from stabbing the other girl in the
neck under all circumstances if a cop
shows up and somebody is wielding a
knife and another person about to stab
them the cop will shoot them
you think the cop went through the cop
said well i mean she's black gotta take
her down
no evidence to that effect at all so
abram kennedy is just a liar and he is
slandering that police officer as a
racist
and so that is number one number two the
broader question
that ibrahim kendy is asking is wrong
the question is not would a police
officer have shot an upper income white
person doing this to another upper
income white person the answer is pretty
obviously yes again because you have a
nine second gap
in which to make the decision to stop
somebody trying to stab the other person
the real question is
in what neighborhoods are these crimes
tending to take place
and what sort of cultural decisions have
to be made to stop those crimes from
taking place
in the first place because the
underlying lie that is being told is
that everyone is equally likely to try
to stab each other with a knife and this
is
untrue this is how you come up with the
idiocy from the left that if the police
officers shoot a disproportionate number
of black suspects
this is because the police are racist as
opposed to looking at the underlying
levels of criminal activity
that doesn't mean that race has anything
to do
with your criminal level of activity it
does mean that crime is not equally
distributed
per capita among the races white people
commit more crimes than asian people per
capita
hispanic people commit more crimes than
asian people than white people and asian
people per capita
and black folks commit more violent
crimes per capita than hispanic folks
and white folks and asian folks
okay those are just basic stats that's
not racist and that has nothing to say
about race as the causative factor
because race isn't the causative factor
but because everyone thinks abram
kennedy thinks that race is always the
causative factor
he believes that no matter what other
explanatory causal factors are there
ranging from single motherhood to
poverty to ingrained generations
of of deep-seated racism going back
several generations right this is the
case that thomas soul makes he says
there are higher levels
of violent crime in the black community
because there's sort of
embedded codes of honor from the
american south there and
a systemic lack of policing for decades
that led to
higher rates of crime in the black
community over the course of a century
but instead of going there he just goes
to it must be that the white police
officer is a racist and it's
his implicit bias and if this has been a
white person he wouldn't shot them
that is shallow it's ridiculous and of
course it is racist because
it says that all white police officers
are implicitly biased and any police
officer who shoots a black suspect about
to kill somebody
is in fact a racist meanwhile you have
ilhan omar doing the same routine
she was speaking at the funeral of dante
wright
again if you believe that these things
aren't political you gotta wonder i mean
ilhan omar
is not as far as i'm aware was not
friends with the dante wright family or
with dante wright
i'm i'm unaware of any prior
relationship she's a congresswoman
who showed up to rip on america and
suggest that the police department
in her city is endemically racist again
based on
no evidence because the dante right
shooting is not a racist shooting we
have it on tape
the police officer a 26-year veteran of
the force shouts taser taser taser
shoots dante right with a gun by
accident then says oh my god i shot him
it is the clearest case of an accident
using a taser
using a gun instead of a taser that it
is possible to imagine and yet it is
being treated as a racist shooting
because again whether it's derek chovin
or whether it is the the
adam toledo case or whether it is dante
wright or whether it is makia bryant it
does not matter
the charge that is levied against that
is leveled against these officers
is not one that they even bothered to
substantiate with evidence it is that
they are racist because
the system is racist so here is ilhan
omar doing that routine
joyce beatty was going to be here and
speak on our behalf
as the chairwoman of our caucus
but just like we've been visited by
tragedy here in minnesota often
she in columbus ohio was visited
by a tragedy of a young woman whose life
was taken
by columbus police okay that
why don't you just miss the entire story
there on purpose on purpose
right joy reid again when you talk about
the the bigotry of no expectations it
seems like
there should be a fairly widespread
expectation that people try not to stab
each other
is that that is that unreasonable that
people should probably try not to stab
each other
and that we should actually have i think
a realistic expectation that people
shouldn't try to stab each other
but according to joy reid knife fights
happen all the time
all the time remember your childhood
remember how many knife fights you're in
you know like every other day in fact my
kids are getting older it's time for me
to get them
the children's book my first knife fight
because they have to get ready for their
teenage years
here's joy read on msnbc creating the
hard bigotry of no expectations
as you look at the circumstances of this
can you just walk us through how police
should act in a case like this
um because you know i was saying on on
my instagram earlier
i remember fights in even high school or
even younger than that where a kid
brought a pen knife or something to
school and
teachers were able to defuse that and
they didn't have guns so um
what do you make of the what 10 20
seconds this officer took before he
opened fire on this little girl
open fire on this little girl you
know i i remember my childhood latin
yeah it was great it was great now
i would love to see a statistical
analysis of how many people
when they are lunging a foot from
somebody with a knife
how how the diffusing went pretty
incredible stuff juan williams has his
own take on this he says you know the
cops should have shot in the air
and like joe biden's style just taking
the shotgun blowing it in the air and
that that definitely would have stopped
her she's in the middle of lunging
well i guess i would shoot the gun not
necessarily at somebody but maybe shoot
the gun
and maybe you know run at the person and
try to disarm them like i don't know i
mean
so wait wait wait you would shoot the
gun in the air like a warning shot
not well hopefully to distract or to try
to stall or something so i could get
or my partner could get the knife away i
see is what i was saying
i don't know i mean taking someone's
wife is pretty strong
i don't either i don't either jesse i
mean jesse policing is tough
work juan williams would have used his
super speed right he would have used his
super speed
maybe like like the flash he would have
frozen time and he would have stopped
makia bryant okay all of this is not
designed to save black lives all of this
ends with more
dead black people because when you
remove the cops from high crime areas
which unfortunately in the united states
are disproportionately minority more
people die good news is that our
politicians don't care at all
democratic politicians do not care at
all okay so cory booker
senator cory booker from new jersey who
presided over newark new jersey one of
those violent cities in america
as mayor he tweeted out something along
these lines
he's tweeted out makia bryant was only
16 years old killed by police
yesterday she deserves justice and
accountability we must reform this
deeply broken system my heart is with
makia's loved ones
yes definitely let's prosecute the cop
who's responsible for saving the other
girl's life
by the way the other girl came out
yesterday and thanked the police officer
for saving her life
does not matter and this is going to
generate all sorts of anti-police
activity you can prepare for it
it's happening in cities across the
nation and then the democrats are
pushing stuff federally
that basically undercut the ability of
police to actually do their jobs the
biden doj as we discussed yesterday
is going to cram down consent decrees on
police departments across the nation
making it more difficult for them to
please the predictable effect of this
will be less policing
in in berkeley the mayor is saying that
they're actually ending low-level
traffic stops in order to reduce racial
disparities
it's pretty amazing statement so we are
no longer going to police crime because
we might
end up nabbing too many black people who
are acting criminally so you know what
quick solution we just won't police
crime anymore berkeley's ending police
stops or minor traffic violations
and this is to reduce racial disparities
and policing outcomes and to focus on
public safety
by making sure police officers focus on
genuine threats to public safety
so we're not going to pull people over
for having
an air freshener on your rear view
mirror or having expired license tags or
not signaling property and focus on
those stops focus those stops on
traffic violations that pose the
greatest risk to public safety
i think this is smart policing and also
will reduce racial disparities
so if they're if they're going to ban
traffic stops to reduce racial
disparities if they really really want
to reduce racial disparities and crime
statistics they just should stop
arresting people for murder
really man it would reduce the racial
disparities in the crime statistics
because unfortunately a disproportionate
number of murders in the united states
are committed by young black men so if
you really want to reduce the
disparities
then really any crime that is not
equally committed by percentage of the
population should not be policed
that seems like the best way to handle
all of this that that
is just a genius way of handling crime
there from jesse eric when we're gonna
look
to the the statistical outcome of arrest
not
who commits the crimes we're just gonna
say any crime that is disproportionately
committed by a percentage of the
population the police react to it
we're just going to stop policing that
crime by the way this is what's been
happening all over california already
and the police have already stopped
enforcing the law at a low level and
you've seen cities just collapse i mean
san francisco is a trash heap
la is a trash heap and it's gonna get a
whole hell of a lot worse
so prepare yourself if you're in a big
city prepare
you're about to see an outfit from big
cities like you've never seen and honest
to god if republicans are stupid enough
to go along with the democratic agenda
their anti-police agenda that will end
with more
dead black people particularly
i can't think of anything more
systemically racist than well i can
think of two things that are very
systemically racist that are being
pushed by the media and the democrats
one is
the bigotry of no expectations right
which is that black people
can't be expected not to commit crimes
therefore we will stop policing for
crimes and blame the cops
and two is why don't we remove the cops
from black neighborhoods
make it impossible for them to police
that is a policy specifically designed
at allowing black people to die but the
media don't care and the democrats don't
care because of course the idea is all
the institutions of america are just
like the police it's not just the cops
the cops are just the most obvious and
the most inflammatory
edge of america's racist systems is why
you have nicole hannah jones saying that
america's police are like the racist
slave patrols she said that america's
policing that's his start in slave
patrols that is just a lie it is a
historical lie
policing began in great britain in like
the 17th century
with robert peel that's why policemen
were
called bobbies right because policing is
centuries old but she thinks there were
no police before the civil war
she thinks she thinks that that policing
now is the same as
see here's the thing about slave patrols
note to the de facto editor of the new
york times nicole henry jones
the thing about slave patrols is that
was a group of evil people
rounding up innocent black people who
are wrongfully enslaved
the police today are rounding up people
who are committing acts of criminal
activity if you are equating
innocent slaves who are held in bondage
by dint of their skin color
with criminals who are committing crimes
largely against other members
of their same race you're a moral idiot
but we already know that nicole hannah
jones is a moral idiot so that's not a
big shock
now when i say that the left has decided
that all elements of american
life are systemically racist they can
use this argument to apply to anything
the beauty of the term systemically
racist it's like the term social justice
when you say some of these terms people
only hear
one of the operative words so when you
say systemic justice
people just hear justice they don't hear
social justice they don't hear racial
justice they just hear justice oh
justice means justice right that means
that people get what they deserve
when you say racial justice that means
that individuals should not get what
they deserve instead they should get
what their race deserves that's what
racial justice
is right social justice means that you
should not get individual justice
you should get what your social class
requires you to get
that's what social justice is
environmental justice justice is a word
that should not require a modifier as
soon as you put a modifier it changes
the entire meaning of the term the same
thing is true of racism
racism means believing that someone is
inferior or that you're superior based
on race
right that is that is racism textbook
racism
you don't need a modifier once you add
systemic you have now transformed the
entire argument
because now the argument is not that
somebody is discriminating
discriminating against somebody else
based on the color of their skin
now you're arguing you don't have to
show any evidence of that any system
at all that ends with the disparity must
in fact be racist without intent
without any argument over to superior as
to superiority or inferiority of
particular races
the system itself is racist which means
it must be torn down you're just using
the word racist
to modify what is the actual operative
word for the left the actual operative
word is always the first word
racial justice social justice justice
doesn't matter in that in that term
when they say systemic racism the racism
part
is the part that really doesn't matter
in that phrase for the left it's just
systemic meaning they want to tear down
the systems perfectly obvious example of
this today
is the democrats are moving to make
washington dc its own state
now in a second i'll explain how they're
legally doing this because normally you
would think
okay well if you want to make washington
dc its own state you actually have to
alter the constitution of the united
states since it is an actual
express provision in the constitution of
the united states that there be
an independent district for the federal
government to be seated so that states
cannot control the federal government
right we've talked about this it's in
the federalist papers it's in the
constitution normally
that would require a constitutional
amendment democrats feel they have found
a way around this
and they're going to shout that you are
a racist if you oppose them i'll explain
how ridiculous this
is in just one moment first i've got to
tell you about the best
office chair on planet earth i mean this
thing is just spectacular
i'm talking about the x chair okay the
extra is just unbelievably good
the secret is not only their patented
dynamic variable lumbar support
which offers unbelievable lumbar
supports your lower back
now thanks to xhmt technology you can
also get heat
and massage therapy while you're sitting
at your desk i mean this thing is like
sitting in heaven
instead of your old uncomfortable office
chair that piece of crap now you can
look forward to spending hours
sitting in the ultimate therapeutic
massager the x hmt delivers heat and
massage technology right to your core
helping increase blood flow
muscle recovery and energy all perks
that make working from home or the
office
an absolute joy okay so i don't
just have the extra i had members of the
office try the extra they are like
begging
me to buy extras for them be like we
actually had this conversation before
the show today it's that good
x chair is on sale now for 100 bucks off
go to xchairshapiro.com right now
that's the letter x chair shapiro my
name dot com
or call one eight four four four x chair
x chair has a 30 day guarantee of
complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month go to xchairshapiro.com right now
use code xwheels for free xwheel
bladecasters ex chairshapiro.com go
check it out best chair
in history the x-chair xchairshapiro.com
right now alrighty
in just a second we'll get to the
democrats using the systemic racism
argument to
explain why they should just be able to
willy-nilly add two democratic senators
first it's time to jump in the ring
catch the latest episode of canada's
it's tonight
9 pm eastern 8 pm central only on
dailywire.com candace is fired up and
ready to go about the events of this
week
she's got a lot to say as you would
expect to get the full uncensored
version of her words you have to become
a daily wire member
join in time to catch tonight's live
stream get 25 off a new membership with
code candace
at dailywire.com subscribe and that's
not all candace is also joined by
another ultimate fighter guest dana
white
president of the ufc dana's awesome
you're gonna love it subscribe now
stream candace tonight 9 p.m eastern 8
pm central only on daily wire at 25
off a new membership with code candice
at dailywire.com
subscribe and make sure you grab the
audio podcast on apple spotify or
whatever your platform of choice may be
also we know you're craving with the
mainstream media won't give you the
truth
so head on over to apple podcast spotify
subscribe to candace today be sure to
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear also again i'm very
excited to announce this weekend
features a new episode of the sunday
special it features an incredible guest
dave portnoy
founder and el presidente of barstool
sports here is a sneak peek
i'll talk to anybody if you have a
problem with me i'll talk to you anytime
any place anywhere
you can bring a hundred people and i'll
debate you by myself
now are there jokes i've made that i
wish i didn't and are perceived
differently now
of course but i've been doing this for
20 years so i'll go through point by
point by point
everything i've ever said and done so am
i maybe i wish i didn't do that
but i know my character and our intent
has always been to make people laugh
period all right you're going to want to
check it out dave porton
i mean he is a live wire he's got a lot
to say and
that dude runs a massive business which
just shows you it's a new type of ceo
out there go check it out this sunday
dailywire.com on my youtube channel ben
shapiro dailywire members get access to
the special bonus content there's a lot
of it from sunday special episodes
don't miss out join the daily wire today
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so the democrats are trying to
use the term systemic racism to force
through a change that would
basically add to democratic senators for
perpetuity that's that's the goal
it's perfectly obvious this is what
they're attempting to do so how are they
doing this so constitutionally speaking
there has to be a federal district that
federal district has historically been
washington d.c
and there are lots of people who live
within washington dc so what democrats
are trying to do now
is they've passed a bill it passed 216
to 210 with all the democrats voting in
favor and all the republicans voting
against
and that bill basically would take the
area that is directly outside of the
federal buildings
and then it would carve it off and call
it its own state
now that's perfectly ridiculous it's
perfectly ridiculous because
if you wanted that area to be
incorporated into a state you could
totally do that
i have a counter proposal why don't we
just take those areas and we'll go and
we will then encompass them in either
virginia or maryland
simple done now you have senators
congratulations
but no democrats want to want the people
of washington dc to have their own
senator
in fact why don't they do this
everywhere they should probably just say
chicago
it really isn't like the rest of
illinois so chicago is going to be its
own state with its own senators now
california has so many different areas
why don't we just make la its own
actual state okay that's exactly what
they're doing
they're basically saying okay we don't
have to change the constitution so long
as we leave these federal buildings in
their own federal district but all the
people who are living in that
surrounding area
who've been living there for you know
generations all of those people are now
going to have their own state
as opposed to being encompassed in
maryland or virginia
again the washington dc district was
designed specifically to be
a federal district if you don't want to
live in a place that doesn't have
senators
fairly well virginia is just across that
river and maryland is just a little bit
the other way
but that's not what democrats are doing
and they have a rationale for why you
must not oppose them wait for it wait
for it it's cause you're a racist
did you see that one coming you didn't
see it coming did you the whole reason
they say that washington dc exists as a
place with no senators is because of
racism now that's absurd on its face
it's ridiculous washington dc was
established when black people weren't
even allowed to vote
anywhere in the united states
essentially so why would so racism
obviously was not the deciding factor
in creating washington dc okay because
that terrible rule about black people
not voting applied everywhere so
obviously if you're creating a federal
district
it's not about whether black people are
going to have senators because black
people at the time couldn't have
senators anywhere
so it wasn't about making a racist
district where black people couldn't
have senators
and now you're trying to retcon the
entire story in order to make it an
outgrowth of racial animus but it wasn't
so nancy pelosi says that dc statehood
is in her dna she's got a lot of weird
crap in her dna if dc statehood is there
a lot of weird things happening in nancy
pelosi's dna
here was the adult speaker of the house
can we have like a leadership class that
isn't adult
that'd be nice seriously so many adult
people at the top of our leadership
structures it's pretty impressive
here's the lady who says that she's
grateful that george floyd died and
thank you for your sacrifice george
here here's nancy pelosi a completely
adult human being talking about how dc
statehood is in her dna along with a
bunch of other weird crap
this should have columbia statehood is
in my dna this is a picture of my father
and the first lady eleanor roosevelt
it was the first time he had a hearing
as the chair of the district of columbia
appropriations subcommittee as chair of
that committee he was known as the
unofficial mayor of washington
because sadly the congress had so much
say
over the uh what happened in the
district of columbia he did not
support that he was all for home rule
and
what would come after that okay so um
in other words actually dc statehood is
not in her dna because her dad basically
was in charge of the appropriations for
dc from the position in congress
so uh no but you know dc statehood is
really all about racism joe biden is
going to be fighting for dc state
remember that guy was a moderate
remember that lie that they told you all
last year so that you wouldn't vote for
trump remember that
the whole thing was that joe biden was
going to be a moderate stabilizing force
in america
well in the last week or so we've had
joe biden endorse a verdict in a
criminal case
we've had joe biden suggest that that
criminal case which had nothing to do
with racism was deeply indicative of
systemic racism across the united states
we've had the biden administration try
to cram down particular
settlements on police departments we've
had the biden administration trying to
force religious doctors into performing
transgender surgeries
i remember all the moderation that was
going to happen yeah it was a lie
and if you believed it you were you made
a large scale error
here's jen sackey saying that joe biden
is going to fight for dc statehood
president biden strongly supports d.c
statehood and he hasn't and
we will all our administration will work
with congress
to get it passed we put out a statement
of administration policy
in strong support of h.r 51 just this
morning
his view is that we are the denial of
voting representation in congress and
local self-government to the 712 000
residents of our nation's capital
violates two of our nation's founding
principles no taxation without
representation
and consent of the governed um and he
will continue to advocate uh for this
passing
uh frankly i think the fact that
northern california hasn't been given
its own state along with southern oregon
probably violates those two provisions
and to say that that violates those two
provisions
is to say that anybody anywhere who
feels non-represented by the government
under which they live
is somehow being deprived of that right
i promise you all the
all the republicans who live in
california which by the way has most
republicans
living anywhere in america live in
california those people
feel pretty non-represented over there
probably they deserve their own state
probably they're being deprived of their
constitutional rights by the same exact
argument
so idiotic because if it's really just
about they don't get to vote for senator
on their ballot
good news we can just encompass the
entire area you're talking about
maryland or virginia then they get to
vote for their senator
but you don't want that you don't want
that because all that would mean is the
same exact number of democratic senators
monder jones democrat of new york here's
what he had to say about this he says
i have had enough of my colleagues
racist insinuations that somehow the
people of washington d.c are incapable
or even unworthy of our democracy
one senate republican said that the dc
would not be a well-rounded
working-class state
i have no idea there were so many
syllables in the word why
one of my house republican colleagues
said dc shouldn't be a state because the
district doesn't have a landfill my
goodness with all the racist trash my
colleagues have brought to this debate i
can see why they're worried about having
a place to put it in
the truth is there's no good faith
argument argument for disenfranchising
over 700 000 people most of whom are
people of color okay here's the deal
again you want to enfranchise all those
people they can vote in maryland they
can vote in virginia i'm perfectly happy
with taking the
exact territory you're talking about and
just handing it to virginia or maryland
but you guys don't want to do that
because there's an obvious game plan
being played here you want two
democratic senators systemic racism is
just another way for democrats to say i
want what i want and i'll call you
racist if i don't get it
meanwhile moderate joe biden he's so
moderate joe biden he's pushing forward
a massive bevy of new taxes
he is now looking for an incredible
increase on the capital gains tax
okay the the capital gains tax that he
is now pushing drove the market
really far down at open today the the
market
took a look at what joe biden was
proposing and dropped precipitously
the market yesterday before he announced
this was it like 34 000 the dow jones
it immediately dropped all the way down
to 33 700.
okay so it dropped about 500 points
immediately
upon all of that happening why because
it turns out that joe biden
his joe biden is the luckiest son of a
gun he is so lucky
because he takes office after a
relatively unpopular president
he takes office amid a vaccination
campaign that he did not initiate and
really had nothing to do
with promulgating and he gets to claim
credit for credit for it and he takes
office
amid a natural upswing in the economy
that's going to happen because
the downswing in the economy was
completely artificially caused by covid
and government policy surrounding covid
so he gets to just float on the on the
tsunami of economic growth that's going
to happen naturally as a result of covet
ending
so his plan is i'm going to ride that
tsunami of economic i'm going to surf on
that tsunami of economic growth
but what i'm gradually going to do is
i'm just going to keep piling on
depressors to the economy i'm going to
inflate the currency
i'm going to raise taxes tremendously
i'm putting place tremendous in
regulations and i know
that the tsunami is going to raise the
tides
and so i won't get blamed for any of
this because it'll take three four years
for it to materialize
so it's great i can just pile as much
crap on top of the economy as i want and
the economy is going to surge back so
strong because it was so artificially
depressed that i won't get blamed for it
ever
but that's exactly what he's doing
according to the new york post joe biden
will propose
doubling the top capital gains tax rate
on investments like stocks and real
estate
according to a new report that sent
stocks reeling on thursday get ready for
bitcoin to boom gang
seriously as a person who invests a lot
in stocks and real estate
i guarantee you if you double the
capital gains tax on that but there
ain't no capital gains on bitcoin guess
what i'm gonna buy a crapload of
it ain't gonna be stocks in real estate
and by the way you know who gets hurt by
that all the people
who are not in the top tax brackets who
have invested in their 401k
the stock market will decline if you tax
people at twice their normal rate do you
think they will put their money there
it means they have to outpace their
gains by 50 just to make the same amount
of money
bloomberg news reported that the new top
capital gains tax rate would increase
from 20
to 39.6 on income over a million bucks
that coupled with an existing store tax
on investment income means federal rates
for investors could be as high as 43.4
percent
for million dollar earners in high tax
states who are heavily and over
well overrepresented in the stock market
rates on capital gains tax could wind up
higher than 50
for new yorkers the capital gains tax
rate could be as high as 52.2 percent
for californians
it could be 57 the leak of the plan
prompted investors to unload stocks on
thursday
the gjia lost nearly one percent of its
value
the idea may be included in biden's two
trillion dollar infrastructure bill
because wrecking the stock market is uh
is infrastructure everything's
infrastructure
a piece of what i bought from home depot
yesterday that's infrastructure
the infrastructure plan was expected to
include capital gains tax hikes
so they roughly match tax rates for
ordinary income the details were not
included
in initial white house blueprints for
the sprawling package i wonder why
because if they had been
all of the financial gurus who've been
backing biden's plan maybe they would
have been quite so sanguine it turns out
all the corporate idiots who've
been backing joe biden's moronic
economic plans they would've been like
oh you mean our stock's going to decline
by 35 percent
yeah we yeah not super into it
conservative advocates previously argued
for capital gains taxes to be lowered by
pegging gains to value into inflation
saying doing so can unleash a real
estate boom by lessening the cost of
large
financial transactions donald trump said
he didn't want to do that because he
would disproportionately benefit the
wealthy
so great joe biden is going to wreck
the s p 500 he's going to wreck the
stock market and this notion by the way
that only rich people are invested in
the stock market
is a lie disproportionately rich people
are invested in the stock
in the stock market but a huge more than
of americans hold stocks and if you have
a 401k you're in the stock market too
and guess who your 401ks gains are
are largely dependent on people who are
in that top tax bracket
investing in the stock market those are
the market makers right large
institutions
hedge funds and large investors those
are the market makers not the
guy who's on his phone with his broker
investing 10 grand that guy's not the
market maker
he said these are ruinous taxes joe
biden is pushing those
not only that joe biden is going to pile
on
huge environmental regulations according
to the new york times
joe biden wants to slash admissions the
new york times says success would mean a
very different america
yeah no kidding experts say the success
would require rapid sweeping changes to
virtually every corner of the nation's
economy
transforming the way americans drive to
work heat their homes and operate their
factories
in several recent studies researchers
have explored with what a future america
might look like if it wants to achieve
biden's new climate goal cutting the
nation's planet warming emissions at
least 50 percent
more than half of new cars and suvs sold
to dealerships would need to be powered
by electricity
nearly all coal-fired power plants would
need to be shut down forests would need
to expand the number of wind
turbines and solar panels could
quadruple it's an enormous
challenge say these experts and by the
way it would of course trigger massive
blowback because it turns out that you
want to radically increase
the cost of living so this is joe
biden's plan
he's going to completely retrigger
american life and he will call you
systemically racist
if you don't go along with him life gets
worse but the democrats approach their
utopian goals
that pretty much sums up their entire
program at this point man if republicans
can't push back on this i don't know
what the hell they're doing in life
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content first
you can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's show is every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you head on
over to dailywire.com this evening at
7pm eastern
tune in i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam's psy events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin